(sound of swiping)
(chiming match sound)
Hey.
Hi.
How's it going?
Good.
Yeah?
You from Spain originally?
Yeah, Barcelona.
Oh My God!
You walked like that the whole way here?
Okay, let's go.
(woman giggling)
You wanna have kids?
YeahI wanna have kids
But I don't want to get married
No? I did.
You were married?
Briefly, yeah.
What about you?
What about me, what?
You know, have you ever, ever been in love?
(whispers) I want you
(passionate breathing)
I really like new things, constant newness.
One, two, three. (both laughing)
If you're honest with me, you will never lose me.
Do you want other people?
Sometimes.
Do you?
Part of me does, yeah.
If you wanna flirt with a girl, you can do it.
What do you want?
I want what to watch you get lap dance.
I wanna spy on you on a date.
Did you like watch me?
Yeah.
The concept of an open relationship is that your explorations with others, are not secret.
So does your boyfriend know that you're here?
You can talk about it.
I want all of this with you, but I don't need to talk about everything from my past.
For love to work, you have to actually pursue it.
♫ Shame don't you know, don't you see what you do to me ♫
I love you just for fun.
Do you love her?
Do you love him?
You can tell me that again, but you can't tell me this, because that's how we work.
I didn't want any of this!
♫ Don't you know, don't you see what you do to me ♫
♫ You think you're freeing , but this is just killing me ♫
I am in love.
But maybe it's not enough.